[Music]
because I've created so much content at
this point on particular figures in
philosophy often zeroing in on a
particular text and thinker and topic
and talking about that specifically I
get a lot of comments and questions and
sometimes challenges that people bring
up where it's clear to me that they
haven't actually read the source
material or if they did they skimmed it
they didn't really engage it and so I'm
creating this video as something I can
post very quickly and easily as a sort
of standard response to those sorts of
things and the very bottom line of it
that I'm going to lay out right here is
you've got to read the text you simply
have to read philosophy there is no
substitute for it in simply watching a
video that's a summary of what's going
on or listening to a podcast or anything
like that now true you could you can get
books on audio but that's also the same
thing as actually like engaging with the
source material so if you've got a beef
with Descartes
you really have to read Descartes or you
might not have a beef with him you might
have it with some other thing that you
read over here that isn't actually what
he's saying so my bottom line is gonna
always be you got to read the text and
that's an important message I do want to
say why it is that you know this is
important and I think in a little bit of
reflection on why people might not get
that reading the text is is often so
important you know for its own sake but
also for the sake of developing a fuller
understanding within the field of
philosophy and in terms of whether
you're going to comment on my stuff and
expect some sort of you know response on
heart so why is it important to actually
read the source text
well because philosophical works are
generally going to be you know quite
complex and there's usually a lot going
on in them there's a few exceptions to
that where you can say well I can
summarize that in five lines but that's
that's really the rarity so you know if
you're gonna criticize Plato or
Descartes or Kant or whoever it is that
you're bringing up you really have to go
back and see what they were saying in
the first place it's not enough to rely
on summaries that you're getting from a
textbook or from a blog site or
Wikipedia or anything like that because
that stuff could be if not outright
wrong it could be mistaken it could be
distorting what's going on and very
often the sorts of objections that
people will bring up you can find the
answer to that considered within the
text though the thinker will often say
somebody might say blah blah blah blah
blah and then you know it'll be
addressed right there in the text I
think it's also important that you read
philosophical texts and you read primary
texts because you don't want to deprive
yourself of that life is relatively
short and we live in this amazing time
where we have access to so much via the
internet pretty much though the whole of
you know ancient through 19th century
philosophy we need a lot of 20th century
philosophy and 21st century philosophy
is available to you you just got to know
how to google and find the texts and
then you can read them for yourself
there's there's no reason why somebody
who has the internet ought to be saying
oh I can't read Plato because you know
there's multiple versions of Plato's
works out there for you
there's many many sites that can give
you good insight into what's going on in
those those works so it's you know it's
critical that you don't deprive yourself
of the opportunity to grow as an
intellect by reading you know Nietzsche
by reading whoever it happens to be
Hegel look at Hegel is very tough you
probably if you want to weigh in about
angle you should read what he actually
has to say so you know there's two big
reasons
another reason is of course my time is
limited and so if you're not doing the
work of actually reading the author as I
constantly tell people they need to do
you really can't expect too much from me
in taking away my fairly rare free time
and answering your objections or
questions that great like when you could
be answering it for yourself by looking
to the text so you know if you want to
book me for a tutorial session that's
something quite different but that's you
know valuing my time properly you've got
to remember that I get a lot of comments
and a lot of questions and even emails
from people in a number of different
formats asking me if I would just you
know take the time to look at this and
think about this set of ideas that they
have there's no way that I could do that
even if I had not just 48 hour days but
even longer you know 72 or whatever
comes with that in terms of
creating greater and greater amounts of
time so you know there's a lot of
reasons why what you want to be doing
your own reading and reflection there's
one other thing I do want to say about
this some people might come back and say
oh but I did read the text well if I'm
posting this video then you probably
want to think about whether you read the
text in an adequate manner for the
material that you're looking at or
whether you did something else instead
so I want to point out two things that
are particularly problematic one is what
we call cherry-picking
right if you're reading and you're just
like picking out certain passages they
say oh this is useful this is useful but
you're not reading the text as a whole
and taking in the person's thoughts as a
whole well that's that's gonna be a
problem right because you're not
understanding how all the parts fit
together into whatever we have of that
author the other thing is skimming you
can't skim philosophical texts that is
you know people may tell you that you
can those people are full of it and they
probably don't know what they're talking
about it's it's just not feasible to do
that with this kind of literature so if
you want to understand Plato you got to
put in the time to read the Plato text
doesn't mean you have to read everything
the guy wrote but if you've got a
question and it's about the Euthyphro
you know maybe devote a whole afternoon
and not just 20 minutes to reading
through that dialogue you know and
similarly with any other philosophical
texts and thinker you have to be willing
to set aside the time and the
the attention the concentration to
actually read through their work if you
want to get the reward so a lot of you
know questions and comments I think can
be addressed by this this video come
back to the key idea you've got to read
the text videos are not a substitute for
a full understanding of what the
philosophical author is up to
[Music]
you
[Music]